bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du
Journal de la rédaction il est 18h si
vous nous suivez en direct comme chaque
soir du lundi au vendredi et voici les
titres de ce 11 septembre non à une
intercommunalité à 800000 habitants
c'est le cri des élus locaux des
Yvelines après l'annonce du préfet
d'île-defance Jean souhaite regrouper
plateau de saclet SaintQuentin avec une
partie de lesson le maire de coignère
Henri paayux qui défend sa communauté de
commune des étans sera en plateau tout à
l'heure avec nous la FSU qui défend elle
la fonction publique se fait entendre
avec plusieurs syndicats elle dresse un
premier bilan de cette rentrée et le
premier constat il est de plus en plus
difficile de recruter des enseignants le
cineset en courour dresse dors et déjà
un premier bilan très positif de cette
année fermé pendant presque 2 ans il a
réussi à reconquérir son public en
profitant d'une bonne programmation cela
fait aujourd'hui 13 ans depuis le 11
septembre 2001 que les deux tours
jumelles du World Trade Center se sont
effondrés le commandant des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelin Sébastien fremmont
vient de sortir un nouvel ouvrage le
deuxième consacré au pompiers de la
ville de New York il se rend chaque
année sur les lieux pour rendre hommage
aux 300 pompiers qui ont disparu ce
jour-là ils participent aux cérémonies
en ce moment en 2001 les pompiers
évelinois étaient partis épauler leurs
homologues américain William l a échangé
avec lui cet après-midi par téléphone ça
nous semble et ça me paraît normal de
venir leur rendre hommage c'est
évidemment à chaque fois une une émotion
très vive ce matin donc à 8h46 et à 9h03
heure de New York donc plus 6 pour vous
on a observé une minute de silence
d'ailleurs avec des collègues et amis
policiers français qui se trouvent ici
pour les mêmes raisons que nous et là à
l'instant même nous arrivons à Brooklyn
pour participer à une messe et à 14h il
y a une cérémonie officielle au quartier
général des pers de New York et pour
finir le tour de lumière qui symbolise
les deux tours duel qui se son effondrés
dans ant 13 an qui sont qui illumineront
le ciel de New York toute la nuit la
semaine prochaine dé j'ai rendez-vous
avec le grand chef des pompiers de New
York pour venir témoigner du soutien des
pompiers des églines comme chaque année
et et continuer à perdurer faire
perdurer cette relation amicale et
fraternelle un partenariat signé
aujourd'hui entre la société égis et
l'université de Versailles 5tin en
Yveline l'objectif est de rapprocher ces
deux entités de faciliter les contacts
l'accord cadre qui a été signé avec le
département universitaire de droit
juridique prévoit la mise en place de
conférence pour les étudiant une
politique d'accueil des doctorants va
également être menée et des stages de
fin d'étude proposé au aux étudiants de
Master 2 était présent le PDG du groupe
d'ingénierie et de conseil le président
de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin et la doyenne de droit et
de sciences politiques Sandrine
Clavel l'étudi à qui on aura montré
concrètement le monde de l'entreprise et
puis bah ils nous aideront à à traiter
nos nos problèmes nos problèmes
juridiques et on espère que bah voilà
ils seront intéressés à poursuivre une
carrière chez nous ou ailleurs dans des
à proximité de d'ingénieur donc de
métier technique et que la technique et
le droit se rencontre bien il y a un
point très important qui est le
développement de ce que nous appelons
les convention CIFRE qui sont des
bourses de doctorat et qui permettent
aux étudiants de faire ce qu' l'on
appelle des tests professionnels
c'est-à-dire de faire une test pour
devenir docteur de l'université et en
même temps de faire cette aise en
entreprise avec un financement de
l'entreprise dans l'objectif de servir
au mieux les intérêts de l'entreprise le
préfet de la région île-de-fance a
présenté le 28 août dernier un schéma
régionale aux élus de la membre aux
membres de la commission régionale de
coopération intercommunale point de
départ d'une concertation au sein de
cette nouvelle instance sur l'évolution
de l'intercommunalité en grande couronne
pour notre secteur le projet engloberait
50 ans en yvelin Versailles Grand Parc
mort pas coinière plaisir et une partie
de lesson une intercommunalité à près de
800000 habitants les élus locaux ne sont
pas favorables à ce projet Catherine
zulato nous donne quelques
précisions une intercommunalité à 800000
habitants allant de plis plir Versailles
Grand Parc 50 an niine jusqu'à Massie
trop grande pour le président de la
casquie cela n'a pas de sens c'est une
très mauvaise idée très mauvaise idée de
vouloir faire un territoire aussi
gigantesque je vous rappelle que 800000
habitants ça serait la plus grosse
intercommunaité de France comment
trouver une gouvernance équilibrée d'un
territoire qui comprendrait des communes
comme la verrière des communes comme
orsé et on irait jusqu'à Vissou on irait
jusqu'à Linas monlerie c'est c'est
complètement fou je vous rappelle de
quelques chiffres notre degré de
intercommunalité au niveau de
Saint-Quentin et de 50 % notre
intégration intercommunale est de 50 %
Versailles grandpc est à 15 % la CAP
c'est à peu près pareil et peut-être à
17 % regarde un petit peu la différence
qu'il y a le président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération rappelle qu'ils sont
membres du plateau de sa cl et il estime
que le travail commun est déjà bien
entamé la vraie Réponse aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est de renforcer notre
coopération intercommunale avec d'autres
mais pour cela on n pas besoin de
fusionner toutes ces intercommunalités
même point de vue pour le président du
conseil général l'UMP pierre ber je suis
d'accord pour que on aille plus loin que
le simple établissement public
d'aménagement qui s'occupe du plateau de
sa clé et donc je considère que les
quatre intercommunalités concerné
peuvent se réunir non pas fusionner mais
se réunir dans une
qui n'est pas une nouvelle hiérarchie
fonctionnaire impôt et cetera mais qui
est un outil de coordination à gauche on
s'interroge également sur ce projet de
large intercommunalité le maire de La
Verrière souhaiterait plutôt valoriser
l'existant la proposition du préfet me
semble pas d'actualité en tout cas nous
n sommes certainement pas là aujourd'hui
la question c'est d'avoir un
élargissement tel que la loi nous y
contraint un élargissement et cet
élargissement doit se faire en fonction
des projets immédiats les élus de de
gauche de l'agglomération ont plaidé
pour une une intercommunalité qui
s'élargit sur le périmètre de l'oïen
donc plutôt du côté sa clé et
l'intégration de morpas c'est une
position sur lequelle nous nous sommes
mis d'accord avec le maire de trappe le
maire de guillancour et le maire de
Manis c'est la position que nous
défendons au sein de l'agglomération du
côté de l'esson les d grincent également
ils ne veulent pas notamment de la dette
de 50 ans en iveline les élus réunis au
sein de la Commission rionale de
coopération intercommunale se serait
déjà prononcé contre ce rapprochement
d'ici 3 mois le préfet de région devrait
rendre son
arbitrage et pour parler de ces projets
de super intercommunalité je reçois
Henri paayux bonsoir Le Maire de coagère
ville qui fait figure de petit poussé au
milieu de cette peut-être future grande
intercommunalité de de 800000 habitants
pour l'instant vous appartenez à la
communauté de commune des étanss et vous
souhaitez la défendre cette communauté
de communes vous avez même fondé un
collectif on va y venir mais tout
d'abord votre réflexion sur cette idée
de de réforme territoriale de regrouper
de fusionner d'élargir ce qui existe
déjà oui ben écoutez je moi je vous
remercie de me poser cette question
parce que je dirais c'est l'avenir tout
simplement de la France qui est en jeu
dans une affaire aussi importante euh il
faut savoir donc que depuis le début des
années 90 lorsqu a été pour la première
fois prononcé le mot d'intercommunalité
après mur réflexion et bien j'étais
immédiatement et rapidement vend debout
je dire contre cette idée de faire des
intercominalités en France et à
l'occasion de mes vœux aux personnalités
j'y revenais régulièrement ceci étant
dit parle toujours tu
m'intéresse est arrivé la loi
Chevenement je passe dessus et puis
ensuite la loi Sarkozy donc qui fait que
en 2010 il y avait approximativement en
France 18000 communes qui étaient en
intercommunalité c'està-dire à peu près
la moitié des 36000 communes que l'on
décompte en France et à part partir de
cette loi 2010 et bien plus aucune
commune ne pouvait rester isolée et nous
étions donc dans l'obligation de rentrer
en intercommunalité donc
l'intercommunalité que vous avez rejoint
il il y a vous l'avez fait de force
finalement vous ne souhatiez pas vous
auriez préféré rester c'est ça la loi
c'est la loi j'avais réussi à défendre
auprès de Michel J préfet des ivelines
une communauté de commune à deux coer
repas ça m'allait bien c'était assez
cohérent maintenant ceci étant dit bien
évidemment en matière de gouvernance
c'est des problèmes et lors que l'actuel
préfet donc monsieur Corbin de bongou
est arrivé à la préfecture de de
Versailles il a décidé de casser
l'intercommunalité qui avait été mise en
place donc par Michel Joe à savoir
également que la commité de commune des
étans rejoignait dans son projet la
communité de commune de ple et Forêts
d'ivline que gère Jean-Frédéric Poisson
euh là-dessus donc le nouveau préfet
arrive il casse tout et euh il décide de
d'autoriser deux communes de la
Communauté de Communes des étants de
rejoindre celle le plan des forêts
d'ivlin et il décide en lieu et place de
rattacher la communauté de commune de
CAN coignère et Mor repa ça c'était le
1er janvier 2014 et maintenant le préfet
de région qui annonce qu'il faudrait
regrouper attendez avant d' arriver là
man encore une étape oui non simplement
ce que je voulais dire donc c'est que
depuis le 1er janvier et bien on
travaille activement au sein de la
communaé commune des étans qui est une
communauté de commune on va dire à
taille humaine avec 3000 habitants on
s'entend bien ça marche bien et
là-dessus donc ça fait pas 9 mois
qu'elle est créée et bien que
aujourd'hui et bien on remet tout ça en
cause et là-dessus donc quand je suis
rentré de vacances fin août j'ai été
stupéfait je dis bien stupéfait et je né
colère pas depuis donc de voir ce que le
préfet de région voulait mettre en place
à savoir donc éclater la comaé de
commune des étanss rattacher le Péré les
Essards et les BRV hier à ple et forêt
d'ivbline et ensuite de rattacher
coignère et mon repas alors là à une
mégapole de 800000 habitants c'est
absolument fabuleux pour versaill
SaintQuentin une partie aussia par pour
aller de du nord au sud et pour aller de
l'est à l'ouest il faut faire les jours
où il y a des embouteillages il faudra 3
heures je dirais pour arriver d'un bout
à l'autre de cette mégapole et je suis
je dirais parfaitement scandalisé ce qui
gêne dans tout ça en fait ce qui a amené
cette réflexion pour le préfet de région
c'est qu'il y a trop d'intercommunalité
93 en Île-de-France il veut les réduire
à 63 à l'heure des économies ça peut SEM
sembler légitime finalement oui légitime
ça c'est vous est-ce que ça peut
permettre de faire des économies non non
attendez alors là
justement non il faut quand même être
sérieux je vous dis moi que cette tout
ce montage techno tout ce montage je
dirais sur l'intercommunalité d'une part
sur la réorganisation territoriale avec
la suppression des départements la
réduction du nombre de régions tout ça
ce n'est que des projets de technocrates
en col blanc et je les dénonce fortement
et ce qui m'attrise dans cette affaire
c'est que je découvre tout doucement que
nos parlementaires sont eux mêm devenus
des technocrate je dénonce je dirais
tout ça et en plus de ça on nous ment il
faut savoir que plus les structures sont
grosses plus ça coûte cher Philippe
segin en 2006 alors que la la France
était pour une moitié en
intercommunalité avait fait le bilan de
l'intercommunalité alors qu'en 90 on
nous avait dit que la muttilisation des
moyens entre les communes allait
diminuer les impôts et bien Philipp a
publié que ça coûtait en 2006 3
milliards d'euros d'impôt
supplémentaires au français aujourd'hui
que la France est entièrement en
intercommunalité je suis convaincu que
nous sommes à 10 milliards et plus
d'impôts supplémentaires donc on nous
ment je dirais pour nous vendre des
projets qui sont purement
technocratiques schéma définitif 28
février 2015 ou le 30 avril si le
Parlement le en décide ainsi il y aura
une mobilisation vous alleer prévoir des
réunions essayer de mobiliser les
citoyens parce que tout ça ça peut leur
paraître aussi assez loin bah écoutez ce
qu'il y a c'est que c'est je je dirais
c'est un sujet parfaitement àide pour
nos administrés ils n'y comprennent rien
du tout mais euh et puis ça les
intéresse je dirais pas ils sont
d'ailleurs largement tort parce que
c'est leur vie que l'on modifie en
profondeur on avait un système je dirais
d'organisation territoriale de de deux
sièclle d'existance qui est né à la à la
fin de la Révolution française euh tout
marchait bien on nous parlait d'un
millefeuille mais ce millefeuille c'est
encore prendre les gens pour des gogos
euh ce mil000feuilles il c'est pas plus
à mil000feuilles je dirais que ce qu'on
va mettre en place aujourd'hui donc on
nous dénoncait ce bfeuille on nous
laissait entendre qu' aurait des
économies le résultat de tout ça c'est
quoi et bien c'est le fait que ce qui a
en perspective derrière parce que c'est
la logique du système c'est la
disparition des communes il faut le
savoir ça alors que les maires sont les
élus les plus appréciés de leurs
concitoyens parce que ce sont des élus
de proximité dans ma communauté de
commune des étants que nous allons
défendre parce qu'il faut bien quand
même qu'on défende quelque chose et pour
essayer d'aboutir à quelque chose ayant
une taille humaine on va dire et bien il
est parfaitement clair que nos clochers
sont à des distances de 10 km les uns
par rapport aux autre actuellement
lorsqu'un administré je dirais veut
aller voir son maire parce qu'il a des
problèmes et cetera c'est facile d'accès
mais demain il va falloir qu'il aille
voir le président de la comité de
commune qui est à 15 km de coière il ira
pas le voir c'est absolument clair et
donc on éloigne les élus de leurs
administrés et puis qui plus est qui
connaît dans le département des ivelines
nos députés européens personne j'ai fait
le test auprès de ma population j'en ai
interrogé comme ça tout un tas je dirais
au passage qui connaît le conseiller
régional les conseillers régionaux dans
le département d'in personne sauf à
coanière parce que il y en a un qui est
en opposition donc celui-là bien
évidemment on le connait bien lier
ficher mais autrement personne ne les
connaît qui connaît les conseillers
généraux qui sont pourtant des élus de
proximité allez on va dire de de de
administrés sur 10 Guer plus et bien je
peux vous dire une chose c'est que
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un test personne
ne connaît le nom du président de la
comité de commune des étants qui a été
mis en place le 1er janvier de cette
année personne et en plus de ça plus
grave personne ne sait que je suis vice-
président de C comité de commune des
étants mais la faute à qui aux citoyens
qui ne s'intéresse pas ou aux politiques
qui malgré les les annonces de dire
qu'on est près de la population sont fin
non mais c'est parce qu'il y a plus de
proximité c'est c'est aussi simple que
ça c'est aussi bête que
ça c'est absolument lamentable moi je
vous dis je vais être extrêmement dur ce
n'est plus de la démocratie on est dans
une espèce de dictature larvée des
technocrates en col blanc avec des
parlementaires qui plus eux les suivent
ce qui semble se dessiner au-delà de
l'intercommunalité à 800000 habitants
c'est aussi une intercommunalité qui
restera très importante pour vous mais
qui est tout de même plus petite à une
autre échelle c'est ce rapprochement
avec Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yveline
les élus de Saint-Quentin les élus de 5-
ans en ieline de la case qui pardon sont
plutôt favorables on va écouter Michel
logier le président actuel qui réagi à
cette idée de faire rentrer ou non
coignère dans la communauté d'aglot de
Saint-Quentin nous sommes ouverts et
d'accord pour intégrer la communauté de
communes de l'Ouest parisien
c'est-à-dire plaisir les clés
villebreeux et on est prêt aussi à
intégrer morpa qui le souhaite et
coignère même si le maire aujourd'hui
est un peu rétissent parce que nous
sommes dans une continuité urbaine et
dans la complémentarité de même moi
j'ouvre toujours la porte commune de la
Vallée de Chevreuse de la Haute Vallée
de Chevreuse pardon et pour avoir
vraiment un vrai bassin de vie un bassin
de vie avec c50s en niblin vous n'en
voulez pas ce qui vous fait peur c'est
la dette de50 attendez on n veut pas ça
c'est clair alors maintenant concernant
la communé commune des étanss donc il
est vrai que fin juin a été créé un
collectif de défense de la commé commune
des étants là-dessus moi j'étais en
vacances j'étais au Portugal quand je
suis rentré donc j'ai assisté à la deuxè
réunion j'ai animé la 3è Réunion et à
l'occasion de cette 3è réunion j'ai
proposé donc à mes collègues de
transformer le collectif en association
de 19 10 j'ai déposé les statuts de
cette association aujourd'hui même à 14h
voilà alors donc on a l'intention de
résister je dirais à tout ça c'est pas
possible quoi et donc on a pris un
certain nombre de décisions dont je peux
parler maintenant on a pris la décision
de lancer une consultation populaire sur
nos cinq communes en tous les cas c'est
acquis à coignère c'est àquis au Péré
c'est àquis au brevvière c'est quasiment
acquis également à moropa parce que
Grégor garestier le maire de Mor donc
dans sa campagne électorale avait promis
aux morpatiens de les interroger sur
cette affaire
d'intercommunalité au niveau des ça le
roi c'est un petit peu plus fou on
connaît pas exactement je dirais quelle
est la position de Raymond paumé
aujourd'hui mais donc on va lancer cette
consultation mais ce qui vous fait peur
qui vous fait peur sur le fond pour
rejoindre saqutins en neline c'est aussi
la dette de Saint-Quentin comment c'est
aussi la dette de saqutins en nieline
qui vous fait peur 400 millions d'euros
alors que coè c'est la deè commune la PR
non c'est les grosses structures qui il
sont complètement ingérables où la
politique s'empare de tout et d'ailleurs
c'est normal les politiques ne
s'intéressent qu'aux affaires qui sont
les grandes villes bon les petites
villes en province a s'y intéresse pas
avec l'intercommunalité on va politiser
complètement la France entière c'est
absolument dramatique je n'ai rien
contre 51 en ivline coignère d'ailleurs
était en ville- nouvelle de 1972 à
1984 j'ai fait partie de ceux qui ont
qui sont battu en 84 pour qu'on en sorte
on en est sorti mais je peux vous dire
une chose déjà c'est que du jour au
lendemain lorsqu'on en est sorti on a
divisé les impôts des coanériens d'un
facteur 2 et je peux vous annoncer
aujourd'hui en 2014 que les impôts les
taux d'imposition de coinière sont
inférieurs à ceux qu'ils étaient en
1984 coière s'est développé il y a
beaucoup de commerces qui commerce se
sont implantés oui parce que j'ai oublié
ma chemise je dirais pour aller les
chercher hein c'est pas pour rien qu'il
y a 850 entreprises à coère mais j'ai
fait un boulot je dirais fabuleux pour
en arriver là alors non non c'est trop
facile
euh qu'est-ce que va P coignère dans
votre truc à 800000 habitants
excusez-moi de parler d'un truc 800
c'est pas le mien en plus à 800000
habitants là on va peser 0 ver5 % mon
repas va peser 2 % mais autant dire
qu'on pèse rien on aura dans C Stru on
sera noyé dans une espèce de de
structure administrative qui é qui qui
qui sera à mon avis parfaitement
agérable totalement politisé c'est dans
le je dirais en matière de proximité
c'est on cherche exactement le contraire
donc moi j'ai rien contre 51 en iveline
mais si 5tin en iveline est associé à
tous les autes là-bas pour en faire
800000 encore moins mais non on souhait
tout simplement et tout bêtement rester
je dirais dans une quité de commune à
taille humaine qui est la quité de
commune des étants et donc on va faire
cette consultation populaire ce sera
organisé très sérieusement ce sera
organisé comme une élection municipale
les gens recevront des lettres avec des
bulletins de vote et cetera il y aura
une réunion il y aura une réunion
publique et cetera et puis euh ce sera
organisé très prochainement dansain et
sera organisé très prochainement il faut
qu'on essaie de trouver une date
actuellement pour mettre tout cela en
œuvre une dernière question à vous poser
on va quitter le le cadre de cette
politique plutôt locale mais comme vous
n'êtes pas longue de bois ça va
forcément vous intéresser vous devez
avoir un avis Thomas tevenou secrétaire
d'État chargé du Commerce extérieur
pendant 9 jours qui quitte le
gouvernement qui retrouve son poste de
député ça vous choque écoutez moi ça me
choque énormément mais ce qui me choque
c'est pas tellement ça ce qui me choque
c'est que il y a eu l'affaire Cusac tout
le monde le sait fort bien et puis
là-dessus aujourd'hui on a l'affaire t
dans le de gouvernement Vals mais je
suis assez estomaqué que on fasse appel
à un homme je dirais sans que l'Élysée
matigon n'est interrogé berc ce soit
penché sur le cursus de cet homme-là moi
moi j'avoue que je ne sais pas dans quel
monde on vit mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est fabuleux quoi merci paux maire de
coignère et contre cette future
intercommunalité que ce soit avec 50 ans
nel nous même à 800000 ce truc comme
vous l'avez qualifié tout à l'heure de
800000 habitants Merci à VOUS quant à
nous av de poursuivre ce journal nous
allons écouter vos réponses à notre
question du jour et forcément on évoque
l'affire tvou votre avis ça Meque rien
de rien de positif de la part des
politiques qui veulent faire des
économies d'un côté surtout vu le les
responsabilités de ce ministre on
attendait qu'il soit blanc comme neige
pour moi il devrait démissionner il a
rien à faire au gouvernement quoi voilà
donc je comprends même pas qu'il soit
encore là voilà parce que si ça
m'arrivait à moi on la fera pas de
cadeau donc voilà et en plus moi je
dirige pas le pays ça salit toute la
gauche parce que bon les valeurs des
gauches c'est pas ça on sait ce que
c'est que de payer ses impôts tous les
ans et en fin de compte en ce moment
avec c'est c'est difficile et puis de
voir des gens comme ça qui sont quand
même à la tête du gouvernement et qui
profite de choses qui devrait pas ça
devrait pas exister quoi
voilà on quitte la politique un peu plus
d'une semaine après la rentrée scolaire
l' les syndicats enseignants premier
comme second degré ont tenu leur
conférence de presse ce jeudi dans les
locaux de la FSU à trrappe il tirent la
sonnette d'alarme sur le manque de
professeur une crise du recrutement
comme nous l'explique Catherine
zulat 4hur de philo au lycée d'hôellerie
et de tourisme de Guill encour 8hur de
technologie au lycée champolon à voisin
le Bretonneux pas de professeur
d'allemand au collège de la clé
Saint-Pierre à hencour 20ur de
mathématiques non pourvu au lycée Émilie
de Breteuil à Montini voici quelques
exemples relevés par le syndicat de
secondaire le SNES à l'occasion de cette
rentrée 2014 des emplois ont pourtant
été créés des créations d'emplois certes
mais qui ne couvrent pas les les ou à
peine les hausses des
effectifs la deuxème problématique c'est
de pourvoir ses emplois étant donné que
on a de gros problèmes de de recrutement
et donc rien que sur l'académie de
Versailles 300 postes d'après le
rectorat qui ne sont pas pourvu suite au
au au concours certaines filières sont
plus touché que d'autres comme les
mathématiques la technologie ou les
sciences physiques mais une situation
que l'on retrouve aussi selon les
syndicats chez les professeurs de sport
et ça c'est nouveau on faisait toujours
le plein sur les concours et là pour la
première fois on n pas fait le plein sur
un concours et la liste complémentaire
qui a été ouverte la première depuis de
nombreuses années n'a pas permis de
faire le plein total ça se voit pas
directement dans les établissements
puisque il y a un volant de de collègues
qui sont chargés du remplacement soit
l'année soit de sur les courtes et
moyennes durées et qui permettent de de
boucher les trous une des raisons qui
pourrait expliquer ce manque d'envie
l'image du métier et le salaire un jeune
professeur des écoles démarre à
1,17 fois le SMIC pour un niveau d'étude
à à Master 1 puisque ils sont recrutés
le concours a lieu au master 1 et
peut-être que ça ne suscite plus de
vocation pour l'heure donc les volants
horaires manquant sont comblés par des
heures supplémentaires et des
contractuel devrait être recruté par le
rectorat les syndicats restent attentifs
cette question ainsi que celle des
rythmes scolaires devrait être à l'ordre
du jour du prochain comité technique
prévu fin
septembre cet été le soleil n'était pas
franchement rendez-vous pour le plus
grand bonheur des cinémas où les salles
ont fait le plein exemple avec le CIN à
en cours une salle qui a rouvert ses
portes récemment après de nombreux
travaux elle a déjà enregistré 70000
entrées depuis janvier elle pourrait
battre des records cette année Antony
rche et Patrick jacqu de di
si cela continue comme cela le ciné va
devoir trouver rapidement un espace pour
construire une 4e salle après 3 années
de fermeture et 18 mois de travaux le
cinéma de proximité et l'enctois fait le
bonheur des passionné de toile pour la
première fois depuis sa réouverture en
avril 2013 le ciné7 est resté en
activité cet été et grâce au soleil
parti en vacances les trois salles
obscures cinquantinoises ont reçu de
nombreux spectateurs on est à fin août
plus 30 % donc on est super content on a
dépassé les 70000 entrées fin août enfin
début septembre en sachant qu'en 2010 on
avait fait 75000 donc il reste 4 mois
donc on croise les doigts et on espère
que ça va continuer comme ça si à moins
de 6 € la place les tarifs sont toujours
aussi attractifs la fréquentation
estival a été bien aidé par le succès du
dernier opus de Luc Besson Luce fin août
la science a dépassé les 4 millions
d'entrées au niveau national et est
devenu le plus gros succès de l'année en
langue anglaise cette hausse d'entrée en
salle reste dans la mouvance nationale
le cinéma français a connu une
augmentation de fréquentation de plus de
15 % par rapport à
2013 non à une intercommunalité à plus
de 800000 habitants c'est la réaction
quasi unanime des élus locaux après
l'annonce par le préfet de région d'un
regroupement de plusieurs agglomérations
d'ici 2015 une première carte a été
diffusée 50 ans neline Versailles mais
aussi une partie de lesesson fusionnerit
au milieu la petite ville de coignère
qui tient à son indépendance comme l'a
expliqué le maire Henri paayux invité du
journal ce soir interview à revoir sur
notre site internet Henry paayux qui
pour l'instant ne veut même pas entendre
d'un rapprochement avec canttin en
ivline fin du journal pour ce soir on se
retrouve vendredi même heure pour un
nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité